[Musique]
depuis deux semaines et ses prises de
position médiatique autour de la
chloroquine l'antiviral miracle qui
selon lui pourrait sortir le monde de la
crise tu coronavirus on ne parle plus
que de lui le professeur raoul
mais qui est vraiment cet infectiologue
excentrique qui divise le monde
scientifique et les français
microbiologiste de formation didier
raoult 68 ans est né à dakar et a grandi
à marseille c'est là qu'il y a mené une
brillante carrière autour de la
recherche des maladies infectieuses dont
il est devenu l'un des éminents
spécialistes en france à partir de 2008
il dirige durant dix ans l'unité de
recherche en maladies infectieuses et
tropicales émergentes
à l'heure actuelle il est considéré
comme l'une des références mondiales
dans la recherche en maladies
infectieuses
reconnu par ses pairs en novembre 2010
il reçoit le grand prix inserm pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière
mais si son travail est majoritairement
salué son attitude fait parfois défaut
grande gueule et franc-tireur le
professeur n'hésite pas à monter
régulièrement au créneau pour se faire
entendre
une attitude dangereuse selon certains
de ses confrères être un professeur de
microbiologie prétentieux et un but de
votre personne n'est pas un crime mais
quand ce caractère nuit à la crédibilité
de votre propos et discrédite un
traitement potentiellement efficace
contre un virus mortel
ça le devient mais aujourd'hui au delà
de la communication la question est de
savoir si oui ou non le professeur
raoult a raison une situation que résume
très bien laurent saccomano président de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé des médecins libéraux de la région
paca
on dira que c'est un héros si on montre
dans quinze jours que ceux qui
l'affirment est valide on dira qu'il est
coupable si le résultat de cette étude
est négative
[Musique]
alors le professeur à où on va en parler
dans un instant les chéris bien sûr avec
rené malleville voilà qui est fan absolu
et a donc vu emmanuel macron lui
demanderez finalement conseil alors ce
qu'il faut savoir sur le professeur à où
il est né à dakar au sénégal en 52
mauvais élèves ils passent un bac
littéraire en candidat libre en 72 il a
failli ne jamais être médecin il a
commencé parcourir les mers comme
matelot dans la marine avant de rentrer
dans l'armée sous les consignes de son
papa médecin militaire il se tourne
ensuite vers la médecine parce que
c'était les seules études que son père a
accepté de financer
il est aujourd'hui catalogué comme l'un
des meilleurs chercheurs français classé
dans le trio de tête pour ses nombreuses
publications dans de grandes revues
scientifiques et médicales et il dirige
l'institut hospitalo universitaires
méditerranée elle méditerranée infection
il travaille avec près de 800
collaborateurs ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que si aujourd'hui son nom tout le
monde là sur le bout des lèvres
eh ben ça fait longtemps que professeur
à ou participent au débat et fait parler
lui on a retrouvé une archive de lui où
il expliquait que selon lui la france ne
serait jamais prête à lutter si une
épidémie arrive et regarder ça c'était
il ya onze ans il y à des virus
pourtant bien connue qui donne
régulièrement des épidémies
considérables comme la grippe actuelle
ou comme l'épidémie de gastro-entérite
tous les ans et à 3 4 5 millions de
garçons méritants france et on voit que
nous ne sommes pas capables de contrôler
ça c'est la même chose au niveau
hospitalier pour les bactéries et pour
les virus notre capacité à contrôler la
diffusion donc la contagion actuelle est
très faible
on sait pas lutter contre ça on sait pas
alors le professeur raoul sachez qu'on
vient d'avoir une info de dernière
minute puisque apparemment ça y est je
vous dit on à la foule qui vient de
tomber la chloroquine pourra finalement
être prescrites par les médecins
hospitaliers
alors on a avec nous un professeur voilà
qui va nous dire ce qu'ils pensent du
professeur raoult et gedo d'image du
professeur house et laurent alexandre
chirurgien urologue et écrivain vous
qu'est ce que vous pensez du professeur
raoul parce que c'est vrai que fait la
une de paris match tout le monde en
parle
mine de rien là aujourd'hui on dit que
la chloroquine ce qu'ils avaient
prescrit il ya quelques quelques
semaines maintenant
donc finalement pour être prescrites par
les médecins hospitaliers
qu'est ce que vous dites à ça aubin on
voit bien que en ce moment dans
l'hystérie est liée à la gravité de
l'épidémie
pour anne au virus la médecine est venue
du show business c'est à dire que on ne
fait plus de la médecine dans les
laboratoires en fait la médecine sur les
plateaux de télé et on voit tout le
monde qui s'improvisent virologue
ségolène royal a donné son avis sur la
chloroquine zemmour il y a en france
maintenant 65 millions de spécialiste
des virus
donc ce n'est pas une situation très
propice à la sérénité nécessaire pour
faire avancer la science
alors vous rené malleville vous dites
quoi quand quand le quand le professeur
nous dit ça c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
les stars vraiment des plateaux télé
c'est des médecins je suis assez
d'accord avec vous et tout le monde
s'improvise médecin tout le monde
s'improvise virologue mais bon le
professeur raoul c'est pas le cas alors
c'est quelqu'un c'est un professeur qui
a beaucoup de chercheurs et de médecins
qui travaillent pour lui france 3
l'avait suivi à 5 ans dans son institut
avec tous ces élèves et vous allez voir
qu'ils blague pas je crois que je vais
envoyer des chroniqueurs la barre garder
ici médecin épidémiologiste se
réunissent une fois par semaine pour
suivre l'évolution des microbes
les chiffres proviennent des hôpitaux et
des laboratoires de la région
cette veille sanitaire lancé par didier
rahout est unique en france
bon là où j'en suis
elle a vu des tableaux le professeur de
monde une nouvelle piste de recherche
jean marc couture un peu sophistiqué
on va prendre si tu veux les vins
bactéries les plus communes
on va guère le regarder ce qui est leur
profil sauvage avec une dizaine de
familles d'antibiotiques et tu vas nous
calculé artificiellement si on enlève
des familles d'antibiotiques qu'elle ait
la chance que l'on aidé un multi
résistants de extrêmement résistant de 3
to peer hésitante alors le professeur
house est un professeur qui divise il a
il a des soutiens comme rené malleville
rené toit d'un de ses soutiens au
professeur un des premiers 11 heures
c'est parce qu'il est riche et ou parce
que tu t'y crois vraiment à tous qui dit
locaux qui dès demain c est non je suis
pas fan de tout ce qui est de marseille
mais accord qui dit et puis surtout ce
qui m'a rencontré beaucoup beaucoup de
lui et je pourrai pas très loin mais
cette espèce de rome
achim qui a eu contre lui tous et tous
ces soi disant sommités parisien et qui
sont foutus contre lui ils ont massacré
jeu ya des dessins des dizaines et des
dizaines d'heures
tu les plateaux télé que ce soit c'est
mieux ainsi ils ont massacré au plus tôt
un corps quand jour je me suis encore
faire des bisous et il m a ni triomphaux
parce que je m'accroche sylla et si la
belle shira où chacun c'est grâce à sa
femme parce que c'est madame à maquereau
qui est allé voir son mari elle aidé dit
mme ashton
le mec là entre que sérieux lors du
retrait par un super type et ne pas
écouter de rabat 2 2 fifrelins que tu
autour de toi et c'est là que macro a
décidé à rattraper
et comme vous invitent à leur rends
compte que il fait partie des 3,4
sommités mondiales vrai et c'est bien tu
as vu un tas de mes dessins qui se
déversait des quartiers j'ai rien contre
eux mais ils veulent et la donner la vie
les soeurs à tâtons relais rené eric
naulleau voudrais réagir
oui non mes professeurs raoult qui l'a
fait naître un espoir immense et la
mesure du mal qui nous accable il ya
quand même des gens qui contestent ou
qui appelle à la prudence et qui ne sont
pas des médecins de quartier qui ne sont
pas il n'ya par rapport aux processeurs
out qui savent de quoi ils parlent
moi je m'en remets à la science mais je
n'en remets pas 100% aux professeurs
cela dit je souhaite de tout coeur
qu'ils aient raison à la fin mais l'a
pour l'instant que ça soit rené aube les
autres on est dans la croyance qu'on n'a
pas la preuve alors lui alors il raison
ou qu'ils aient tort alors on a on va
voir un patient qui a été vraiment qui
vient d'être guéri à la chloroquine du
corona virus juste quand vous entendez
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont pour qu'ils
sont contre vous qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est voilà tout parce que
j'ai vu voilà il ya plein de sons sur
les plateaux télé qui en mettent plein
la gueule aussi aux professeurs à oloron
alexandre vous vous en pensez quoi
bon il faut savoir que 98 % des patients
guérissent sans médicaments sans
échappement il n'y a que 2 % création
qui ne guérit pas donc que vous preniez
une bière de la piste de chameau ou 2
les corses de boulot vous avez 98% de
chances de guérir en prenant rien ou en
prenant n'importe quoi donc le problème
c'est de prouver que la chloroquine
c'est mieux que 98 %
estrosi a guéri avec doc la chloroquine
mais il aurait guéri 100 tonnes rockin
puisque 98 % des gens guérissent sans
aucun médicament sans traitement donc il
faut faire attention dans
l'interprétation des résultats
il va y avoir plein de gens qui vont
guérir avec la chloroquine il aurait
aussi guéris sans que leurs hôtes keane
donc aujourd'hui il faut que l'on fasse
l'étude qui est en cours l'étude
européenne qui est en cours parce qu'il
faut bien savoir que l'étude qui a été
fait en chine est totalement négative il
montre une efficacité nulle
une absence totale d'efficacité de la
chloroquine l'étude qui a été publiée
ces deux derniers jours donc il faut
faire attention ne faudrait pas qu'on
lance des espoirs absolument fou qui
seraient déçues dans quinze jours quand
la grande étude va sortir ses premiers
résultats
il faut être vraiment très prudents
aujourd'hui et on est un petit peu dans
une hystérie sur les réseaux sociaux
avec avec la chloroquine il faut raison
garder il y a des gens qui ne sont pas
du tout convaincu par exemple dans le
point aujourd'hui le professeur lescure
le le célèbre infectiologues dit que
l'étude du professeur raoul peck une
onde scientifique
donc je ne regarde pas tant sur les
travaux du professeur raoul
aujourd'hui il faut faire bien attention
est en tout cas jusqu'à présent les
études sur la chloroquine sont négatifs
chez l'homme elles sont positives en
éprouvette
mais elles ne sont pas positifs chez des
vrais malades alors il a dans une vidéo
youtube le professeur à où s'est montré
rassurant sur la longévité du des
rustres garder selon lui ne passera pas
le printemps
et juste après on aura un patient qui
pour lui a été guérie du coup on a virus
grâce à la chloroquine regarde il n'y a
pas deux affections virales
respiratoires qui ne soit pas
saisonnière ça n'existe pas donc
paradoxalement la chose la plus
intelligente qui a été dit c'est par
trump qui a dit écoutez au printemps ça
va disparaître parce que c'est vrai que
la plupart des infections virales
saisonnière s'arrête au printemps tandis
que fo si qui est le grand scientifique
qui dirige les neiges lui vu devenir
gâteux parce qu'il dit ça n'a pas
d'importance c'est ça qui est important
les 10000 morts de grippe n'ont pas
d'importance parce que ça va s'arrêter
au printemps et qu'on a les accents me
refais à dix mille morts comme depuis le
début de l'année de grippe aux états
unis perçu ce zéro par le corps d'un
virus donc le sens de la réalité a du
style
alors on a on à monsieur lang qui est
avec nous c'est un une personne qui a
été donc traitée pour le un kobe de 19 à
la chloroquine et qui est guéri
aujourd'hui voulait nous faire un petit
un petit témoignage
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes denis saint
vincent oui ça fait bonsoir
alors on l'a on l'a un téléphone c'est
ça alors merci d'être avec nous je vous
en prie vous vous avez été guéri grâce à
la chloroquine qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire que vous avez été guéri gala grâce
à la chloroquine et pas comme dit
laurent alexandre parce que voilà c'est
le temps qui a fait que vous avez guéri
ou parce que voilà vous avez été vous
avez pris du paracétamol mais j'ai été
contaminé je pense aux alentours du 10
mars
j'ai commencé je suis à l'hôpital et on
m'a prescrit un traitement très simple à
base de doliprane et d'antibiotiques
j'ai eue grâce à mon médecin traitant
accès au traitement à la lettre le
rockin associé à l'antibiotique
azithromycine et en l'espace de 48
heures j'ai vu vraiment une différence
dans les réactions de mon corps par
rapport à une sorte de ça vous donne une
somme de 2 rebonds en fait les symptômes
sont sont très variées j'ai une perte de
boue qui a été très vite on sent
vraiment que son corps se bat quand on
creuse des tranchées et 2 ledit midi et
le traitement vous permet de rebondir je
vous redonne rapidement l'énergie pour
remonter alors vous avez senti vraiment
que la chloroquine avait accéléré votre
guérison l'a complètement les gta 3 mg
de paracétamol j'essayais de diminuer en
le doze ans que c'est quand même le
maximum le corps santé que le corps
lutte
il n'y avait pas d'amélioration nette du
coup je me fatiguais bon et en plus une
angoisse parce qu on est touché tout
soir ça mais on connaît pas ce virus
seront connais pas ces symptômes on ça
varie en fonction des personnes vous
avez cette terre de goût et l'odorat qui
est intervenu très rapidement on est un
peu à la croisée des chemins
parce qu'on ça ressemble à rien à partir
du moment où ge déclenché ce traitement
une accélération vers le but et sans
recul c'est à dire que de jour en jour
j'allais mieux et j'ai même pu arrêter
paracétamol ou du quatrième voilà donc
c'est vrai que voilà ça c'est un
témoignage intéressant merci à monsieur
lang qui nous a téléphoné de nice merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec merci pour
votre témoignage nous c'est important on
va reparler de la chloroquine on va
parler de ces chaires raout bien sûr
avec rené avec monsieur alexandre plus
tard merci vous l'avez indien du strict
à dire monsieur lang oui oui je je je
pense que on a de la chance d'être à
nice parce qu'on a eu un accès rapide à
ce traitement
il y a des masques dans toute la ville
il ya des solutions qui sont mises en
place
les personnels soignants on peut
aujourd'hui se déplacer à avoir un
masque rapidement et surtout il ya une
généralisation des tests
donc je pense que j'ai eu de la chance
par rapport à la situation et que les
actions du maire en tout cas font que
ici on est soigné et rapidement voilà
c'est et j'espère qu'un maximum de
personnes